let's start today with the U.S Mexico
border no matter how many times the
right Wingers say it the U.S Mexico
border is not open under Joe Biden now
you might be saying David of course it's
not open how could anyone believe that
it is open there are millions of people
based on polling that believe the border
is open under Joe Biden as a result of
some change or series of changes that
were put in place when Donald Trump left
and when Joe Biden became the president
of the United States this is not true
and we're going to look at it right now
and the reason we're going to look at it
is it's good to Once get everything on
the record so that in the future when
this talking point comes up when the
Maga people call me on the Friday show
and they say but the border is open
that's one of the problems I have with
Joe Biden we can now create a record a
reference point to go through the
various elements of this because this is
a I would call it relatively common
assertion
perpetuated by right-wing media by
right-wing politicians and it is Flowing
down to just random right-wing voters
the claims are numerous one of the
claims that's often used to say the
border is open is you will hear things
like we're catching so many people at
the border because Biden opened it by
definition if we are catching people if
we are stopping people if we are taking
people into custody by definition the
border is not open now when you want to
look at has policy changed have numbers
changed is there something tangible
maybe with the wall or with border
agents that Joe Biden has changed you
find that very little has actually
changed the Biden Administration has
increased the capacity of shelters and
processing centers at the border to
better manage the flow of migrants but
that's not evidence of an open border
it's evidence of being able to more
quickly and more efficiently say who is
merely Crossing illegally and needs to
be put into sort of the deportation flow
and who is seeking Asylum and needs to
be put into that bureaucratic process
neither of those are evidence that the
border is open in addition to that there
are border security claims Biden
demolished border security
there's no evidence of that and you can
find each aspect of this widely
documented by the relevant agencies
funding requests for Customs and Border
Protection under Biden are almost
identical to under Trump when it comes
to how much money is being requested by
the respective administrations for
border security in general
Staffing levels when you say oh well
Trump had way more border patrol than by
that's absolutely not the case U.S
border Patrol Staffing levels were
slightly higher under Obama around 21
000 total
under Trump they were in the 19 000
range plus or minus a few hundred border
agents under Biden they're in that same
19 000 range Plus or by a plus or minus
a few hundred so Staffing levels
identical
funding requests essentially identical
um beyond that what about policy what
about policy on turning people around or
taking Asylum requests or whatever the
case may be border authorities you may
be shocked to hear under Biden are
enforcing immigration laws just like
under Trump immigrants continue to be
expelled detained or allowed in based on
the same standard as to whether they are
passing initial screenings and what
exactly their business in the United
States is the Biden Administration
although they did stop construction of
the wall
few hundred miles of wall uh the Biden
Administration is repairing all existing
border barriers adding detection
technology to make it easier for border
patrol to identify where do we need to
go
I'm not even telling you these things
because I like or dislike them I'm just
telling you what the truth is about
border policy it is absolutely the case
that Biden hasn't added any new barriers
which I think is the right policy
because the wall was quite a silly idea
but Joe Biden is fully funding the
repair of existing barriers that were
already there okay so you have two
groups of people you have people that
are coming to quote sneak in as the
traditional illegal immigration is sort
of characterized and then you have
people coming to seek Asylum and then in
addition to that you do have people who
are coming over for work legally uh or
coming over for work illegally but then
going back to Mexico there's all of
these different scenarios
all of those categories are being
handled the same way that they were
being handled under Donald Trump you can
agree with the policy or disagree with
it you can say we should have some kind
of permanent status for so-called
dreamers or we should not you can say I
like the wall or I don't like the wall
fine everybody is entitled to that
opinion but in order to really talk
about this we have to acknowledge that
funding hasn't materially changed from
Trump to Biden border Staffing hasn't
materially changed from Trump to Biden
Joe Biden is repairing existing border
barriers Joe Biden is funding new
detection technology for areas of the
border that are that are more remote and
as far as policy goes we have the title
42 thing
which Trump put in and then Biden's
looking getting rid of but it's not
clear whether so there's that but beyond
that we have evidence of nothing more
than another completely fabricated
talking point that's the truth the
border is not open